buongiorno a tutti per il lavoro che
faccio mi viene spesso chiesto di dare
una definizione di creatività di
spiegare come la creatività funziona
ecco oggi cercherò di farlo e
soprattutto cercherò di dimostrarvi una
teoria che ho formulato legata anche
alla vita comune la mia presentazione
inizia con con il primo uomo sulla luna
e purtroppo sia stato usato
precedentemente quindi la mia
presentazione che dovrebbe essere sulla
creatività forse sarà la meno creativa
della storia
la cosa però interessante
cerchiamo di legare questo questo fatto
che effettivamente ha sconvolto il mondo
e ha ispirato il mondo alla creatività
ed entrato nell'immaginario comune non
soltanto per il progresso scientifico
che ha portato ma soprattutto perché ha
dato speranza a tutti noi
chi ha pensato di mettere l'uomo sulla
luna ha avuto un'idea creativa non
soltanto diciamo per l'idea che esiste
da secoli di arrivare sulla luna ma
anche ma per come portarlo sulla luna
ecco perché ha avuto un'idea creativa
perché ha pensato qualcosa che prima non
c'era la seconda cosa però interessante
su questo fatto è che quello che
ispirato gli umanità
in realtà è nato da un conflitto tra
unione sovietica e stati uniti
in realtà questa questa comunque questa
questa questa tensione tra questi due
paesi questa concorrenza ha accelerato
questo questo questa conquista la
creatività e naturalmente legata a
un'idea di conflitto
se voi pensate dell'idea nell'idea di
storytelling c'è naturalmente il
concetto di tensione si sia sempre una
tensione emotiva per poi risolverla
orson welles non so se sapete a una
famosa citazione lui disse una volta che
i borgia in 30 anni di conflitti
tensioni uccisioni produssero leonardo
michelangelo il rinascimento mentre la
svizzera in 500 anni di pace ha
inventato gli orologi a cucù negli anni
sessanta in inghilterra con tutte le
tensioni di classe di razza di religione
sono nati gruppi come gli who e rolling
stones e led zeppelin quanto nella
stessa inghilterra quando questi
conflitti sono andati scemando sono
venuti fuori il web
olè bananarama e adesso vi faccio vedere
la definizione che dal campo di cdx
meriti di creatività e dell'abilità di
produrre idee originali e inusuali per
creare qualcosa di nuovo o innovativo
ecco io questo concetto e lo contesto un
pochino perché la creatività non crea
mai qualcosa di nuovo dal niente anzi
nell'idea di creatività c'è proprio il
riciclo io ho una definizione di
creatività leggermente diversa per me la
creatività è il prodotto di due unità
che non sono mai state messe in contatto
e questo contatto non è indolore provoca
una piccola esplosione provoca un
conflitto
se voi pensate ad esempio i beatles
tutti diciamo la produzione musicale
nasceva da questi piccoli conflitti tra
paul mccartney e john lennon
io adesso vi faccio vedere alcuni esempi
di creatività che nascono da appunto da
mondi diversi che vanno a collassare
insieme anzi se volete indovinarli opera
e rock
esattamente porta bohemian rhapsody
horror e musical
ieri durante le prove qualcuno ha detto
gli abba
rocky horror picture show
[Applauso]
bossman boss mafiosi e stress
forse la serie più bella che sia mai
stata creata i sopranos samurai e
science fiction esattamente star wars
salmone avvocato è più importanti
california royce
ok la seconda cosa che ti vorrei dire
per quanto riguarda la creatività che
bisogna assolutamente sfatare il mito
dell'idea della grande idea da big di a
l'idea geniale ma forse siamo abituati
anche da topolino archimede pitagorico
che anche a queste idee improvvisa in
realtà le idee creative sono un percorso
si raggiungono pezzettino alla volta
bello non ho mai inventato il telefono è
seduto in bagno oppure quando si quando
il conto quando si è svegliato è stato
un percorso lungo la stessa cosa
michelangelo quella capitolato cappella
sistina
la creatività quindi in realtà è fatta
di piccoli step se unito a quello che vi
ho descritto prima del dell'idea di
conflitto
noi avremo dei piccoli conflitti che uno
dopo l'altro portano a una soluzione
quindi sorta en plus long long time
solutions è questa un po la la mia
teoria che basata su due assunti uno che
piccoli conflitti evitano grandi
conflitti
la seconda cosa è che questi piccoli
conflitti ci portano ad andare avanti ci
fanno guardare avanti
portano progredire adesso vi faccio
vedere se portiamo questa teoria nella
nella vita reale su come noi ragioniamo
su come il nostro cervello funziona
l'uomo è il gene camp geneticamente
predisposto a prosperare in situazioni
di conflitto
e questo ci viene ovviamente dalla
nostra eredità genetica però il nostro
cervello nostro cervello è fatto di due
parti una razionale un e razionale che
continuamente collimano nella nostra
vita e la nostra giornata in 24 ore
noi abbiamo circa 300 400 piccoli
conflitti interni o con altri che
dobbiamo risolvere immediatamente ad
esempio che belle scarpe
sì ma costano troppo vorrei andare a
giocare a calcetto però devo ancora
lavorare questo fa parte del nostro modo
di ragionare il cervello nostra ragione
per conflitti e grazie a questi
conflitti noi progrediamo andiamo avanti
una coppia sia dei piccoli conflitti
quotidiani questi conflitti portano alla
coppia a devolvere a diventare qualcosa
di diverso da come era prima
se invece questi conflitti non ci sono
abbiamo due situazioni o il total
agreement però che porta dopo un po a
non discutere di niente e alla noia
oppure a un crash improvviso che è la
litigata furiosa che spesso e volentieri
la separazione in entrambi i casi però
non c'è il futuro per la coppia i
piccoli conflitti ci portano ad andare
avanti
noi ci siamo evoluti grazie a questi
piccoli conflitti oggi anche per colpa
dei social media
noi siamo molto preoccupati del giudizio
degli altri per cui ci auto censuriamo
cosa facciamo
invece di mettere in discussione i
nostri assunti le nostre convinzioni o
quelle degli altri
cerchiamo di allinearci a dei macro
pensieri per cui abbiamo delle
situazioni o di total lineman oppure i
grossi di grossi scontri
in entrambi i casi non progrediamo non
avanziamo non evolviamo i politici cosa
fanno
invece di mettere in discussione
i nostri i nostri pensieri i nostri
assunti cercano di rassicurarci sulle
nostre posizioni in modo che manteniamo
e ci sentiamo rassicurati coccolati in
queste posizioni però in entrambi i casi
non evolviamo a singapore dove
coesistono tantissime religioni ci sono
delle delle regole delle leggi di
armonia religiosa per cui i capi
religiosi vengono invitati a
confrontarsi costantemente su temi
religiosi e questo ovviamente per
evitare conflitti
io vi invito a fare una prova
se voi avete una discussione provate a
farla come con un'altra persona
camminando come vedrete che se nella
discussione mentre state parlando vi
fermate voi cercate di mantenere la
vostra posizione
voi cercate di non andare avanti
se invece mentre state discutendo
continuato a camminare
questo conflitto li sta portando
qualcosa di altro i vasti sta facendo
avanzare verso il futuro
torniamo ad esempio iniziale il motivo
per cui armstrong il primo uomo sulla
luna è ancora così forte nel nostro
immaginario e per cui gli ha fatto un
passo e facendo un passo
noi guardiamo sempre in avanti
lui sì lui la definizione che gli ha
dato è un piccolo passo per l'uomo un
grande passo per l'umanità che potrebbe
quasi essere una definizione di
creatività perché la creatività ci aiuta
a guardare avanti ad essere positivi ad
andare a letto
sperando quel giorno il giorno dopo sia
un giorno migliore ecco se posso darvi
un consiglio è quello di cercare di
avere questi piccoli conflitti
confrontatevi scontrate v tutto questo
vi porterà ad andare avanti
porterà progresso e il progresso porta
sempre speranza e oggi il mondo ha
veramente bisogno di speranza la
speranza
si raggiunge si costruisce soltanto
guardando al futuro e il futuro è
qualcosa che per definizione non esiste
e questa forse la definizione migliore
di creatività grazie
[Applauso]